ce que je voudrais leur poser comme
question déjà c'est que le droit de
grève c'est un droit constitutionnel on
est d'accord jusque là vous avez le
droit mais il y a des certaines limites
d'accord parce que moi je suis
dirigeant de société j'ai des camions et
je dois livrer des gens tous les jours
d'accord là par exemple des émissions je
vais aller continuer à livrer à monter
dans mes HLM à livrer des des
lave-vaisselle et cetera mais au bout
d'un moment quand je fais 3 heures de
queue d'accord pour faire du gasoil
encore vous aurez rien obtenu on peut
être d'accord avec vous on se dit bon
très bien vous avez obtenu bon je sais
vous avez 6 %, vous avez non non non non
10 mais pour l'instant ça en négociation
donc juste je vous explique on parle de
6% vous savez qu'il y a pas que des
agents chez Total il y a l'appartement
il y a des infirmiers des boulangers etc
d'accord je suis d'accord 6 % vous avez
obtenu apparemment enfin ce qu'ils
disent un 13e mois un équivalent d'un
13e mois en prime nous on veut pas
rentrer moi j'espère même que vous en
obtenez 48 des mois d'accord c'est pas
le problème mais au bout d'un moment il
faut savoir s'arrêter on sort du covid
on sort de restriction la tension
sociale j'ai filmé avec des bagarres
dans les stations il y avait des
bagarres bien sûr il y a beaucoup de
bagues moi je sais très bien mais au
bout d'un moment
il y a plusieurs personnes il y a des
petites gens d'accord je dis pas que
vous êtes des lentilles etc vous vous
travaillez vous méritez votre salam mais
au bout d'un moment il y a des gens mais
qui peuvent pas mettre du gazole qui ont
pas le temps d'attendre tu dois avoir
des parents des gens malades soigner
vous voulez faire ça jusqu'à quand en
fait au bout d'un moment jusqu'à quand
vous allez le faire en fait ce que dit
mot le patron il faudrait nous expliquer
après votre position bien entendu il dit
au-delà du gouvernement au-delà de votre
patron est-ce que vous pouvez vous c'est
un petit un acte citoyen que vous
demandez pensez peut-être voilà tous les
tous les gens qui sont bloqués qui ne
peuvent pas travailler la France qui est
paralysée et est-ce que vous pouvez pas
négocier sans continuer la grève c'est
un petit peu ce qui semble bloqués en
fait
parce que moi je suis dans le service
expédition c'est à Lyon en fait c'est
une raffinerie qui est dans la banlieue
Feyzin voilà c'est ça exactement et en
fait on bloque pas on les camions
rentrent ils peuvent rentrer mais il y a
personne dedans c'est tout hein après
moi je suis venu aussi pour expliquer
qu'on n'est pas juste sur les salaires à
la base c'est vrai que tout le monde
nous salit en fait c'est une question de
pour l'opinion publique en fait c'est un
peu ça mais nous on est surtout sur
l'investissement dans nos raffineries et
sur l'embauche parce que nous raffinerie
elles sont pourries elles sont ouais
qui est plus de moyens qui est plus ou
moins exactement aujourd'hui elles sont
en état de délaboration exactement
il y a des investissements à faire des
gros investissements à faire et il faut
les faire pourquoi vous voyez que nous
raffinerez continuer à durer il va vous
avez peur de quoi un accident un
accident il y a de la population tour
voilà et malheureusement c'est vrai
qu'on le sait très bien moi j'ai une
famille aussi je fais la queue comme
vous aussi j'en suis conscient ma mère
mon père ma femme c'est pareil et j'en
suis conscient et j'en suis le premier
je veux dire pareil je suis prêt en
otage aussi comme vous mais
malheureusement on fait de l'essence
j'aurais fait du pain il y aurait pas de
pain mais ça va peut-être touche un peu
moins de monde vous voyez ce que je veux
dire là vous là vous pas voilà c'est
vrai que vous avez un poste clé qui
paraît exactement le pays
aujourd'hui si on en est excuse-moi si
on en est là c'est qu'il y a vraiment un
problème vraiment on n'a pas vu c'est un
mouvement comme ça vous êtes heureux
dans votre métier ou pas oui oui on est
très heureux totalement énergie on est
très heureux vous êtes très heureux donc
pourquoi vous êtes heureux moi j'en suis
pas à ce point-là mais oui quand même
pour une entreprise la première
entreprise c'est pour ça que vous
travaillez là-bas ça fait 28 ans 28 ans
toujours heureux vous avez passé des
moments vous êtes oui j'ai toujours
travaillé pour cette entreprise vous
considérez comme gagnant bien votre vie
bien je pense je gagne ma vie comme tout
le monde vous avez passé une belle
carrière là-bas j'ai passé une bonne
carrière pourquoi aujourd'hui vous
faites grève alors pourquoi aujourd'hui
on fait grève en fait aujourd'hui on
fait grève pour tout ce qui se passe
c'est à dire pour tout ce qui est
augmentation de salaire parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'inflation et ben elle
est là quand
notre première demande à 10 % la
négocier autour de jade l'année dernière
qu'on a rien eu hein je vous rappelle
qu'on a rien eu et il faut rappeler
aussi qu'il faut des milliards de
bénéfices excusez-moi pour les milliards
de bénéfices juste pour qu'on soit clair
c'est pas parce qu'une société fait des
milliards de bénéfices d'accord qu'il
faut de permettre de je vous expliquer
le marché le marché du pétrole d'accord
c'est une un oligopole vous avez ecson
vous avez shell vous avez total vous
travaillez pour un fleuron de la de la
société française
augmenter de 50 % d'accord il y en a
certains ils trouvent ça choquant mais
un mec qui rapporte des milliards je
suis désolé vous c'est un sale non mais
juste écouter
de l'argent ce monsieur c'est l'étranger
total que son argent à l'étranger le
plus le plus oui mettre d'accord
justement
cette question elle revient souvent la
question de de David qui dit qui fait
gagner de l'argent à à cet homme il y a
beaucoup de gens qui disent mais c'est
c'est lui qui a monté la société c'est
lui qui a fait qu'est-ce qu'il y a
Daniel mais c'est c'est la situation de
du monde entier les patrons gagnent
beaucoup plus que les emplois mais au
bout d'un moment faut le faire on est
nous on n'est pas en fait vous êtes des
petits malins là vous voyez que le le
revendications salariales ça commence à
comme les gens sont déjà exaspérés parce
qu'ils font là que et qu'en plus c'est
pour on dit que c'est pour des salaires
qui sont alors moi je suis sûr que
totalement sur les 5000 donc ça je
voulais je vous l'accorde mais on est
sur des moyennes je suis désolé je
commence à 1000 euros ça va être
vraiment mal vu dans la population donc
là vous comprenez mal vu mais il faut
penser à nous si vous savez dans les
conditions qu'on travaille vous le savez
oui il y a pas de souci
et là donc vous nous servez le couplet
qu'on a entendu aussi plein de fois
c'est par c'est pour parce que vous
pensez à tout le monde aux gens qui
habitent à côté des raffineries tout ça
c'est c'est bien bravo vous êtes on vous
a bien aiguë à la CGT vous avez dû
prendre des cours pour vous [ __ ]
d'oeil du monde c'est très bien mais
nous on croit pas tout ça de toute façon
on y croit pas vous vous avez envie de
bloquer le pays je suis désolé c'est
plus de la grève c'est du blocage de les
pays et la prise de tâches c'est un
terme très fort mais qui correspond à la
réalité pour un choix
juste une fois que votre vous aurez
obtenu je l'espère vous allez obtenir ce
vous voulez il y a pas de problème on
vous le souhaite d'accord une fois que
vous allez rentrer chez vous
tranquillement vous avez pensé à tous
ceux qui ont galéré tous ceux qui ont
peut-être perdu des emplois à cause de
ça parce qu'il y a des patrons ils ont
pas le temps d'attendre je suis patron
ça veut dire que il y a des gens ils ont
pas le temps d'attendre ils vont le dire
dehors
ma formation elle travaille ma femme
elle travaille pas
l'essence elle fait la queue pareil j'ai
compris je t'explique à bout d'un moment
tu vois c'est en plus il parlait que
c'était une grève préventive donc depuis
comme on a des grèves préventives donc
ça ça m'a choqué organisé c'est tout à
fait je vais t'expliquer je travaille
RATP avant je sais ce que c'est les
syndicats d'accord ce qui vous paye
c'est total donc normalement on ne mord
pas la main de celui qui donne à manger
on est d'accord ou pas donc au final
mais on n'est pas là pour moi on est là
pour protéger les salariés et on est là
pour les salariés ils sont dans la peine
et qu'ils ont un problème justement
vous êtes syndiqué vous savez que vous
les syndiqués vous êtes une société dans
la société ça veut dire que nous on les
raté par exemple il y avait quelqu'un il
dit un soir je peux pas travailler je
vais faire une heure une hache vous
savez la chienne
c'est le même principe sauf que là non
c'est pas français tout un pays c'est
même pas genre vous bloquer on peut
comprendre par là on va être le centre
du monde on va être mais là c'est tout
un pays
à 800 km d'ici quand on vous dit que
vous bloquez le pays vous répondez quoi
Olivier ça aurait pu être débloqué
depuis longtemps la direction et le
gouvernement aussi ça fait ça fait 15
jours ils ont pas ils ont pas voulu
rentrer en discussion avec nous depuis
15 jours proche
du blocage donc c'est nous qui demandons
voilà ce que nos revendications là comme
je te dis aussi l'investissement faut
pas obligé faut pas oublier que
l'investissement je te dis les
raffineries elles sont dans un état
de travail
moi j'ai une question à vous poser si on
vous dit vous avez les 10% euh donc
valorisation mais qu'on refait pas les
raffineries je veux dire tourner ou pas
franchement Cyril moi pour moi perso moi
je préférerais qu'il refasse qu'ils
investissent dans les raffineries moi
sur tous les jours
avec des chauffeurs je travaille avec
les chauffeurs les chauffeurs j'étais
encore avec eux ce matin ils ont
interpellé les gens de la direction de
la maintenance ils ont dit c'est une
honte
l'état de du matériel l'état du matériel
le matériel qui charge les camions là
les quêtes de chargement d'accord dans
un état déplorable et ça fait 15 ans
qu'on les alerte qu'on leur dit c'est il
va avoir il va me parler
tout ça il y a bien un contrôle de
sécurité qui passe contrôler votre
société elle est elle est agréée ISO
de sécurité on vous laisserai pas
travailler dans ces conditions moi je
vais poser une question série laisse-moi
poser juste une question bah vas-y pose
une question magne-toi aujourd'hui
l'essence elle a augmenté on va parler
vite fait avec Sergueï à cause de l'euro
mais c'est le pétrole qui a un peu
augmenté mais on a perdu en euros donc
on perd sur le marché d'échange et
maintenant il y avait des taxes qu'ils
avaient mis à l'époque les taxes carbone
les ils avaient augmenté la TIC pour
justement gratter un peu d'argent je
vous
salaire il augmente je veux bien mais
répondez-moi à ma question que je me
pose dans ma tête d'abruti si Thomas
total
moi je t'ai pas dit que je reprenais pas
non Cyril non j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit
s'il le donne bien sûr oui on va prendre
ça mais moi ma priorité et je te le dis
moi ma priorité c'était l'investissement
et l'embauche d'accord on travaille
qu'avec des intérimaires on a des
intérimaires les raisons
porte-parole de 40 millions
d'automobilistes qui est extrêmement
remonté pourquoi Pierre bah on comprend
on le sait c'est pourquoi mais qu'est-ce
qui se passe moi je voudrais vous poser
une question aussi en fait elle est très
simple moi je vais pas rentrer dans le
débat est-ce que votre combat est
légitime ou pas je vais être honnête à
titre purement personnel comme au titre
de tous les automobilistes vous nous
forcez à prendre des opinions qu'on a
pas à prendre exact ça vous regarde vous
dans un conflit qui vous oppose à votre
direction le problème
c'est que sur la route il y a 40
millions d'otages il y a 40 millions de
personnes qui aujourd'hui
de personnes aujourd'hui cette voiture
qui se retrouve attendez attendez s'il
vous plaît il y a 40 millions de
personnes aujourd'hui qui se retrouvent
dans des situations extrêmes alors je
vous donner quelques quelques petits
exemples et vous allez me répondre je
vais vous parler d'un automobiliste sur
l'autoroute A1 22 km de bouchon pas
d'accès à la station-service
désincarcérer de son automobile
heureusement vivant parce qu'il a été
percuté par l'arrière alors qu'il était
sur la bande d'arrêt d'urgence comme les
autres c'était juste le dernier de la
file pour pouvoir faire le plein je vais
vous parler des quarts de transport
scolaire qui ne pourront pas partir dans
beaucoup de départements avec des gamins
qui vont pas pouvoir aller à l'école je
vais vous parler des ambulanciers qui
sélectionnent dans l'Indre-et-Loire
leurs courses et celles qui sont trop
loin qui ne peuvent pas les assumer je
vais vous parler des 5 millions de
gamins qui chaque année
se passe à l'hôpital en urgence la nuit
et je vais être très franc avec vous il
y a une question que je comprends pas
si votre combat est vraiment légitime
encore une fois c'est pas
je vous jette pas la pierre là-dessus
mais je comprends pas un la grève
préventive premier point ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est que quand la porte
des négociations s'ouvre vous continuez
ou en tout cas pas vous directement mais
votre syndicat à vouloir ouvrir la porte
avec un pied de biche alors qu'elle est
déjà ouverte pour les négociations et je
vais vous dire ce que je comprends pas
encore plus quand les infirmières vous
savez celle qu'on appelait les héros il
y a encore quelques temps et qu'on était
tous heureux de trouver
celle que les chauffeurs de taxi que
vous empêchez de bosser actuellement
accompagnaient gratos sur leur lieu de
travail mais vous savez comment ils ont
fait grève elles ont bossé
et là je vais être très franc avec vous
c'est là où j'ai du mal à vous
comprendre et c'est là où les 40
millions d'automobilistes ne vous
suivent plus les sondages montre
aujourd'hui que les Français ne vous
suivent plus soyez plus intelligents je
vais vous donner une idée je vais vous
donner juste une idée reprenez le boulot
mais marquez le fait que vous avez
besoin d'investissement sur votre lieu
de travail parce que là vous allez
toucher les gens vous les aurez les
médias ils seront là le message va
passer faites des banderoles marquez vos
différences mais retourner bosser pour
montrer que vous êtes avec nous et pas
contre nous c'est vrai c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
non non non non
tout ça je sais j'en rigole mais j'en
suis conscient et on en est tous
conscient de ça et je sais madame
excusez-moi mais je sais vous êtes chez
agressive d'habitude vous êtes pas comme
ça
on peut les écouter quand je vous dis à
chaque fois c'est pas tout blanc ou tout
noir c'est pas tout le monde a raison et
un tel a toujours raison tout le temps
il y a toujours il veut dire il y a il y
a parfois des choses qu'on ne sait pas
des choses qu'on a besoin d'apprendre
donc arrêtez dès que vous voyez des gars
de la CGT lui dire bah non c'est des
ouvriers on en a besoin d'égalité aussi
ce genre de discours je veux pas ici je
vous le dis je veux pas ici voilà les
gars c'est c'est insupportable
je vous comprends je vous assure je
comme je vous dis j'ai une famille aussi
travaille tous et je sais la galère que
les gens en ce moment sont en train de
vivre mais déjà les responsables je sais
qu'on est on est mais les responsables
je vais vous dire franchement c'est la
direction totale et le gouvernement ils
auraient pu se réveiller avant et pas
laisser pourrir ce truc
notre hiérarchie la direction a fait un
de la raffinerie passe devant nous on
leur demande mais depuis 15 jours
pratiquement il y a rien il y a rien il
nous ignore ils ont attendu que hier
monsieur Macron parle à la télé et qui
est tout à coup ça s'est tout débloqué
et voilà là il y a ils sont en train de
négocier voilà mais je veux dire moi
pour moi pour moi franchement la
direction à son rôle à jouer dans cette
pénurie là juste Olivier et David pour
les Français qui nous regardent
elle va durer encore longtemps cette
grève on parle mardi d'un blocage total
il va se passer quoi mardi parce que
maintenant moi ce que j'ai entendu déjà
c'est que les autres voulaient se mettre
aussi il y a EDF je crois j'ai entendu
les dockers où je sais plus ouais les
routiers aussi j'ai entendu mais nous la
base c'est plus vite mais je sais parce
que je vous dis quelque chose en fait
aujourd'hui moi je vous vois et je vois
je lis voilà moi je sais souvent des je
sais d'arranger les choses à notre
petite échelle et c'est vrai que je suis
aussi triste pour mot pour Pierre et
pour tous les automobilistes que pour
vous parce que je vous vois ce soir et
je vous vois aussi triste de ce qui se
passe autour de vous parce que vous
dites toute l'opinion publique et contre
nous aujourd'hui c'est vrai que voilà
c'est compliqué pour vous d'être dans
votre situation dans votre position vous
pouvez pas faire marche arrière est-ce
que il y a des convictions politiques ou
des des pas de pressions politiques mais
est-ce que la nupet sont pas voilà et
essayer de vous récupérer ou essayer de
faire monter le chaos en France à
travers vous et
voilà donc vous voilà par contre j'ai
pas entendu le
les raffineries qui sont
trop vieilles ça j'ai jamais entendu je
regarde tout malheureusement
malheureusement en communication je
pense que la direction totale est mieux
placé que nous le petit ouvrier
communiquer on est parti
j'obtiens je reprends le travail donc
après j'ai pas entendu du jour au
lendemain les murs et vont être lisse
les tu vois ce que c'est un travail de
longue haleine j'ai envie de te dire
s'il faut s'il faut faire de la
maintenance dans une raffinerie c'est
sûr que ça va pas se faire du jour au
lendemain ça fait 15 ans là tu me dis ça
fait 15 ans il y a des choses qui sont
qui sont récurrentes en fait si tu veux
il y a des choses qu'ils auraient dû
faire déjà depuis longtemps et puis
qu'ils ont laissé traîner et voilà et
pour nous qu'est-ce qui vous empêche ce
soir là il est quand même un petit peu
de monde derrière l'écran qu'est-ce qui
vous empêche ce soir de répondre à ma
question en disant mais ok c'est une
bonne idée ce que vous dites monsieur
chaserez 40 millions d'automobilistes ok
on va le faire on va mettre un brassard
un truc on va en parler à nos directions
puis on va retourner au boulot pour
débloquer la situation pourquoi vous
faites pas mais moi
mais si vous l'avez ce pouvoir tout le
monde a du pouvoir
alors juste Olivier et et Olivier
d'aller à la base c'est qui qui pourrait
débloquer c'est pas la direction qui
pourrait l'indiquer tout le monde dit ça
si tout le monde Olivier ça fait 15
jours qui nous ont pas contacté qui
parle à personne hier on avait la
responsabilité qui a dit on va demander
à chaque grévite ce qu'il veut faire
aujourd'hui
donc je vous pose la question vous
voulez faire quoi non forcer des âgés
ces assemblements
Nao qui sont en train de se faire c'est
ça donc on va
ce qui nous propose c'est ça et après on
avisera avec les ouvriers on ira faire
voter nos ouvriers et on leur demandera
est-ce que ça vous va est-ce que ça vous
voit pas mais on n'est pas là pour faire
pour couper quoi que ce soit en fait
c'est la majorité vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est à 100 personnes mais si
toi tu veux travailler ils vont
t'empêcher les autres mais tu peux pas
c'est ça une majorité de grévistes
tu me dis je peux pas maintenant toi tu
veux
tu dis c'est bon il a raison
qui sont d'accord avec vous et qui vont
dire en fait c'est un mouvement qui va
faire que 1 2 puis voilà le mouvement à
l'envers comme tu l'as fait comme ça tu
peux le faire l'envers en donnant envie
en mettant en brassard noir tu passes
chez Cyril il t'a ouvert la porte voilà
je reprends le travail si dans un an
j'ai rien qui s'est mis on sera tous
témoin l'opinion va être de votre côté
et ce sera l'opinion franchement
je suis pas content ça c'est sûr je
saute pas toujours hein donc aujourd'hui
Olivier et David vous attendez la
Réunion si la Réunion est concluante
vous pouvez reprendre le travail quand
demain matin
tous les matins avant de reprendre le
boulot on se réunit tous qu'est-ce qu'on
en pense déjà il y a la direction qui
vient aussi alors donc là après vous
allez faire une réunion avec les autres
grévistes et on va vous dire voilà on
nous a proposé ça est-ce que ça vous va
où est-ce que ça vous va pas donc
aujourd'hui vous demandez 10 %
d'augmentation si on est l'embauche des
intérimaires voilà ce qu'on a beaucoup
d'intérimaires
ils les prennent il les jette une bonne
maintenance de notre outil de travail
dès la fin de cette réunion donc ce soir
vous allez demain matin vous allez
savoir si voilà ça vous convient ou
[Musique]
il faut combien de temps puis-je pour la
norme huit jours
retour à la normale je pense que vous
travaillerez du dimanche si ça revient
normal
vous avez envie de retravailler avec
vous ça s'arrête là mais sinon
vous avez envie de reprendre le travail
oui bien sûr
d'être depuis 3h du matin on est debout
voilà
je peux juste poser une question
quand vous faites grève après c'est
indiscret ou pas c'est On vous retire
votre pays bien sûr
bien sûr
avec la CGT c'est des cagnotte de
solidarité
il y a des et ils mettent des chèques
s'ils veulent donner et puis
Olivier moi je voulais vous dire
j'espère que vous allez retravailler
j'espère que tout va rentrer dans
l'ordre on va voir des nouvelles demain
matin donc on vous en parlera bien sûr
demain soir on espère que ça va
reprendre et ici comme vous l'avez dit
c'est vous pourrez vous travaillerez
même ce weekend ah ouais mais de toute
façon comme je vous le dis on a on n'est
pas là pour embêter on ferait du pain on
ferait plus de pain mais là de l'essence
malheureusement et voilà on sait que ça
touche plus de monde ici on juge
personne on jugera jamais personne voilà
on est où les donner la parole aux deux
quoi
sur ce plateau voilà et qu'on respecte
la dame elle m'en veut encore hein
d'aller voir
en plus il est beau gosse David merci en
tout cas d'avoir été avec nous